j'en termine quand même avec la
cérémonie d'ouverture qui est un d'un
genre un peu particulier mais qui va
utiliser finalement le même dispositif
juridique pour la cérémonie d'ouverture
on va utiliser le même dispositif
juridique parce qu'on est sur un
événement
majeur donc ce sera le même dispositif à
la nuance près que nous allons avoir un
périmètre qui va euh qui va aussi
concerner les piétons alors il ne
s'agira pas évidemment d'imposer des des
restrictions mais le ministre l'a
rappelé sur France 2 ce matin pour des
des raisons évidentes de contrôle et de
sécurité il est bien évident que pour
les personnes qui rentreront dans le
périmètre de protection anti le
périmètre antiterroriste de la cérémonie
d'ouverture que nous mettrons en place
comme nous l'avons annoncé quelques
jours avant sans donner encore
évidemment le le le moment de sa mise en
œuvre pour des raisons évidentes de
sécurité évidemment que dans cette zone
contrairement à ce qui va être fait sur
les périmètres rouges et les périmètres
de circulation routière automobile
motorisé nous allons également mettre en
place un contrôle que j'ai annoncé hier
sans en donner les modalités Paris qu'il
y a une phase de concertation qui
s'ouvre pour la cérémonie d'ouverture il
y a des mers d'arrondissement il y a la
mer de Paris avec laquelle je dois
évidemment discuter nous mettrons
évidemment en place un périmètre qui
tout en permettant aux personnes
d'accéder au périmètre de la cérémonie
d'ouverture évidemment bah sauf le jour
de la cérémonie où il faut avoir un
billet mais en dehors de ces de ce jour
de la cérémonie quelques jours avant il
y aura un contrôle qui portera aussi sur
les piétons dont le le le le les
modalités ne sont pas encore déterminées
donc nous verrons ça pendant la
consultation mais qui va reposer sur le
même cadre juridique que celui que je
viens d'exposer hein voilà ce sera on ne
va on les les gens devront probablement
s'enregistrer euh pour se rendre dans
certains lieux sur le le le périmètre de
la cérémonie